grazie buonasera a tutti
quella che stiamo vivendo oggi tutti è
un'esperienza lo è per voi e lo è
soprattutto per noi che siamo da questa
parte del palco e aveva ragione estive
stamattina è bello vedervi tutti in
mutande per chi è da questa parte l'idea
è quella in qualche modo di lasciare il
segno di comunicare qualcosa di
coinvolgervi di coinvolgere i vostri
sensi di regalare appunto un'esperienza
ma come fare
occorre capire cosa ci stimola nel
ricordare un momento un po come quando
si era bambini beh da bambini e
difficile ascoltare più facile
ricordando ripeti faccio ricordare una
cosa con il vissuto e noi adulti non
siamo tanto diversi infatti l'esperienza
la migliore forma di apprendimento
io e il mio team realizziamo
installazioni immersive installazioni
interattive che hanno il compito di
regalare un momento speciale alle
persone che al compito di essere
ricordate quando le persone tornano a
casa e fare questo ci siamo accorti che
ci sono tre tipologie di situazioni
chiave che caratterizzano queste questi
momenti importanti e noi tentiamo di
toccarle tutte con la tecnologia non è
facile perché dipende dalla situazione
dipende dai mezzi che abbiamo a
disposizione
come per esempio questa presentazione
qui ci sono io ci siete voi e abbiamo
questo schermo o forse no
cerchiamo di attrarre con il diverso con
il difficile e è difficile veramente
trovare cose che ad oggi siano diverse
da da altri tutti fanno qualcosa di
diverso tutti fanno qualcosa per essere
originali però tutto si muove troppo in
fretta oggi tutto è troppo veloce e
questo dal giorno alla notte
in verità cerchiamo scalpore cerchiamo
di stupire però lo scalpore non è altro
che la rottura di un equilibrio
el'inaspettato in un momento di confort
ma perché così perché il nostro cervello
lavora per patterns interpreta tutto ciò
che lo circonda e per questo elastico è
sensibile alla ripetitività del vissuto
riconosce ciò che ha già visto e questo
da sempre perché è primordiale conosco
questa situazione per cui è tutto ok
quindi ragioniamo per connessioni
emotive prevedibili e ne dà equilibrio
c'è rottura è questo il più delle volte
genera gioia dell'inaspettato però per
la rottura serve qualcosa da rompere
save appunto l'equilibrio questo per
esempio il ritmo visivo è quella la
rottura quindi per noi la prima
caratteristica è appunto lo scalpore che
però non sta in piedi
se non c'è il tempo il ritmo in studio
da noi lavoriamo di arti visive quindi
senso più importante per noi è la vista
cerchiamo qualcosa di diverso cerchiamo
una rottura che lo facciamo appunto
quella tecnologia che ci aiuta ad andare
fuori dagli schemi aiuta con soluzioni
formule e la prima cosa che siamo
chiesti perché utilizzare una superficie
bianca è piatta quando ci sono altre
forme interessanti
questa è una struttura in materiale
povero ma immaginiamo per un attimo che
sia un prodotto da presentare all in di
un pezzo d'arte oppure ancora un
monolite di marmo beh in studio da noi
ha teneramente chiamata la moralità ed è
pensata come esempio per far capire come
si possa raccontare attraverso la forma
perché di fatto questo può essere
potenzialmente un nuovo livello di
comunicazione ma immaginate gli usi
immaginate in un negozio una borsetta
una borsetta che comunica con la propria
pelle i vari materiali di cui è composta
oi vari colori in cui è proposta ma
anche un passo indietro
l'arredamento o ancora qualcosa di più
grande
noi un passo indietro abbiamo fatto e
abbiamo pensato come lo schermo può
essere un limite perché anche la luce
deve essere incastrata all'interno di un
bulbo perché non può essere libera di
essere disegnata sulle pareti
può essere questo un modo di creare
luciano convenzionale diversa beh si può
ed è così che noi l'anno scorso abbiamo
pensato in presentato vedo
questo è un angolo del nostro studio le
pareti sono bianche e l'arredamento e
bianco
tutto accade in tempo reale con il
soggetto il sistema è simile a quello
che stiamo utilizzando oggi queste sono
quelle che chiamiamo atmosfere i massi
le pareti vive fonti di luce diversa da
quella cui siamo abituati e gli spazi
cambiano viene rotto il limite spaziale
tutto questo viene fatto con il
controllo attraverso uno smartphone
attraverso un atto che mi permette di
cambiare le atmosfere in base alle mie
emozioni in base a quello che voglio
vivere in quel momento del mio ambiente
quindi parliamo di ambiente pulsante
parliamo di stimolazione dei sensi non
ci sono più schermi non è più una
comunicazione tra persone persone ma e
comunicazione tra persone e ambiente
immaginatevi la lobby di un hotel
entro in hotel come legislatore e
l'ambiente attorno a me cambia a seconda
della situazione del tempo dell'evento
oppure l'esperienza con il cibo in un
ristorante dove mentre mangio qualcosa
viene esaltato attraverso le pareti che
mi circondano
e ancora musei spazi piccoli come
imbarcazione yacht fino a grandi spazi
pubblici sono geometrie che comunicano
quindi perché avrei il limite di questo
schermo bianco quando i verità abbiamo
tutto questo
questo è il coinvolgimento spaziare dal
secondo punto è esperienza immersiva e
architettura che cambia pelle che esalta
i concetti che aumenta i miei sensi e il
mio spazio che comunica emozioni
fantasia
questo è il teatro indoor più antico al
mondo ma immaginatevi una visita
immersiva
immaginatevi di poter vedere attraverso
la struttura come concepito immergervi
nella struttura dell'opera vedere come
progettata tutto tram tramite una
tecnologia completamente nascosta
immaginatevi di poterla esplorare
con un altro tipo di comunicazione un
altro modo di di penetrare gli ambienti
che andiamo a visitare quindi non più
dei chioschi che sembrano più simili a
tablet datati ad oggi o mura di monitor
che urlano gli sconti la tecnologia ad
oggi può essere molto di più in questo
senso può infatti dare valore delle cose
rivelando informazioni può intrattenere
in modo funzionale poi esaltarne la
maestosità o simularne il passato
esponendo le sue stesse e cicatrici
ma tutto questo
non ha valore senza un terzo elemento
probabilmente il più importante
l'emozione noi i nostri sensi siamo al
centro di tutto questo tutto il resto è
un'alchimia dei mezzi che raggiunge
l'apice solo se noi come maestri
d'orchestra
stiamo attenti a bilanciarli tra di loro
e che ci esprimiamo come esprimiamo le
emozioni attraverso i sensi quindi il
mezzo deve essere coerente con i
contenuti come qua altalex che racchiude
e impacchetta gli interventi e le idee
sotto un'unica sotto un unico titolo 20
necid che non è altro che piantare il
seme di ciò che nel futuro diventerà
grande è parte integrante di ciò che
siamo
grazie